The URIMatcher we just coded is central
to coding our Content Provider.
And will be used in the implementation
of our core Content Provider methods.
We've given you Tests to help you along
the way as you code Weather Provider.
Since several of these tests
have been re-purposed from
the database test you helped write.
You may want to look at how the content
provider calls replace the SQL
database calls in tasks such as test
location table and test weather table.
But before we can start implementing
step four in testing our content
provider, we need to register
it to the AndroidManifest, so
that Android knows about it.
Once the weather provider has been
registered with the package manager, we
can use an Android utility class called
the ContentResolver to refer to it.
The ContentResolver locates our class
using the Content Authority and
makes direct calls to the weather
provider on our behalf.
Add a provider tag into
the androidmanifest.xml file to register
the WeatherProvider class with
the Content Authority as defined in
the WeatherContract.
Note that the two fields you need
to populate in the provider tag
are android:name and android:authority.
Uncomment the testProviderRegistry test
within TestProvider,
to test to see if you've
done this correctly.